did you watch 2k16 you're outta wiper
fluid bro I know I've been out of wiper
fluid for ages what if a bunch of dirt
gets on the front it's a whole new game
we're gonna go find the best fried
chicken from any grocery store in Los
Angeles we're trying to represent all
the chains of America today that's great
let's get to the nitty-gritty what makes
good Fried Chicken good rubric Beauty
Chris penis is the number one factor it
needs to be moist moist
we got 69 we got wow factor I'm a
drumstick man I'm about I'm a breast boy
you're dressed full you want to be our
wingman I can be the wingman all right
Kevin's our wingman hopefully we'll
assemble a team of sighs by the end of
the day I think we should go to food for
Less first this food for Less feels like
you're preparing for an earthquake you
look good yeah [ __ ] you watch 2k16 one
breast one thigh one leg one wing good
for less how'd you know so you think
it's just a regular box right oh no
turns into a handle I can't handle it
I'd say we do Beauty right off the bat
that does look terrible creepiness and
we're gonna say grab moisture solid
moist we mean it kind of worthless
seasoning this is the saltiest part well
how do you rate your drumstick I think I
can do a lot better there's better
chicken titties out there the wingman
thumbs up thumbs down okay okay
no thigh guys present so the thigh will
go with us there's a policeman obviously
over there
I say no wow factor ghosts actually not
okay we will not film any more on the
gigawatts 2k16 now we're going to funds
Hollywood Vaughn's Hollywood
yeah my favorite views me as I do my
drive you know what fuels me will keeps
me alive
you know use me till the day that I die
it's chicken [ __ ]
and the chicken fried chicken what
they're just putting it out that's
amazing well you just put that fried
chicken out there this is stuff you 16
did you hear that I'm gonna say that
this beauty is killin it's pretty gold
and beautiful there's bunches I thought
it was going to be there more than
while a long time okay we would prefer
ubi yeah you don't have to weave around
your face and distort your voice Oh
moisture moisture would you say it has a
WOW factor and now our first honorary
tie guy you picked that thing pop dry I
know I'll tell you that I don't think
it's the best we may get in here man not
even like I know like like way up can
you just say ticking watched you guys 16
with that okay it's just like a tag why
not we made a friend although she
ditched us immediately but we're gonna
keep on continuing on the chicken watch
2k15 it's a guy over there and he looks
like a thigh it's a girl over there
she's a drumstick yeah she playing the
drums with a bunch of drumsticks and a
bunch of broken breasts with a bunch of
[ __ ] dick I tell you what twenty-nine
advice projects the chicken back Kevin
alright well the chicken is the closest
living relative to the great
Tyrannosaurus Rex who doesn't know how
far the t-rex is fallen alright we're
about to go into Whole Foods getting
ready for people to be really hot or
hippies smells good chicken watch 2k15
we're doing a video right now you want
to come with us and do it yeah let's go
there it is vini is definitely obviously
do you want to be our wing lady sorry
Kevin no it's not crunch mine's dry the
least seasoned the leg was mediocre just
breast is disappointing neither a good
experience nor a negative experience
okay definitely know a while back here
for me no sexy not whole foods are great
for healthy food for unhealthy food not
quite a win all right so chickens to
distinguish between more than a hundred
different phases so they'll always
remember you all right oh I feel
terrible all right
is it beautiful we didn't even do judge
Wow its moist enough but it's like the
most bland you have any seasoning
I'm good crunch I didn't ask you that
hey feeling not great general and
because of the ticket the chick is how
would you rate your leg Phyllis hi class
give me the camera you try the wing well
its crunchy its moist can you please
keep it to the thumb rating Kevin Oh Luc
I'm sorry upper thumb no wow factor
no sex nut I feel like you're high on
chicken right now Kevin
the truck it won't it won't
yo give me some chicken I don't mean to
bad
which came first the chicken or the egg
hey that's with a chicken fat Kevin did
you know that chickens can taste
sweetness
chickens are pretty [ __ ] versatile
then you should know how sweet that rap
was chicken as I can't by the way no
can't they can't they can't
it says sons behind a tree so much
chicken wants to get 16 she can watch
2k16 chicken watch 2k15 I'm doing my
phone buggers hard they're seasoning
there there there was crunch it was also
moisture there so balanced mine rest
it's big like a D but it's a score of an
egg it's a long strand of hair coming
off that somehow would that come from
[ __ ] hell I'm gonna be a [ __ ] I kill
babies i guy I'm so happy just gets my
wow factor he gets my sexy nod I think a
song might just be the right way to end
the chicken watch 2k15
you dance with us